Cray, a planet very similar to Earth
Thanks to the actions of many heroes
, the peace of the world has been preserved, but the
gods have been destroyed.
[Music]
Kether Sanctuary A closed sacred kingdom where dictatorship progresses
due to repeated civil wars and natural disasters
.  Military empire
[music]
Blunt Gate
It is an exchange exhibition between the planet Cray, once called Stargate, and understanding
Science powerhouse
Dark States A lone
hero has achieved unification With the
demonic relatives, no, in the depths of the Chronicle
Amazing body Yan
Great sage
Modi of the teachings of
the 1st line An emerging nation where the first country 2 and the sea country Megalanica became one
A mansion
whose earnest
prayers will reach you
.